christina wolfe is always on the move
she's on the supervisory board of seven
companies ranging from energy suppliers
to construction firms
she previously worked in senior
management in the u.s and asia but then
fancied the idea of a new kind of
position a supervisory board member
every 10 years you take stock and wonder
what to do next
and every 10 years i'd always had a
change
later i moved into management so when i
headed into my 50s i thought it was time
for something new
german corporations have an extra board
of part-time advisors to supervise the
executive board among the firms she now
helps oversee is hotif the international
construction giant had a troubling 2014
laying off a thousand staff in germany
alone a welcome challenge says volv
what's crucial is having a backbone
standing by your decisions and posing
awkward questions
you can't get nervous even if everyone
else has a different opinion
and you have to have the self-confidence
to be able to persevere
supervisory boards are largely made up
of men today volf is prepping for a
meeting with a mid-sized company
despite her own success she feels women
have so far been chronically
underrepresented at the board level
we needed a form of leverage to change
the proportion of women on supervisory
boards
saying you know it'd be nice if you had
more women at the top and then relying
on companies to respond voluntarily
hasn't really achieved much
women currently account for 1 in 10
supervisory board appointments the quota
recently introduced by the government
aims to raise that figure to 30
starting in 2016.
but her colleague a financial recruiting
services manager insists a set quota is
counter-productive
it's not going to change overnight
what i fear is that it will result in
unqualified people being appointed
skipped half and back we have vast
numbers of qualified women in germany
and you can hardly claim that all the
men currently in those positions are
that great
and that's an opinion shared by
germany's confederation of women
business leaders the body began calling
for a quota years ago in the meantime
training 150 women at its seminars for
budding supervisory board directors the
chairwoman is determined to shake up
what is until now being very much a male
domain
boys clubs
it's the kind of boys club what
recruitment consultants are telling us
is that they oversee 15 to max 20 of
appointments today with the remaining 70
to 80 percent still made through
internal networks
that means women gaining access to
traditionally male dominated networks to
secure the top jobs in business and
industry christina wolfe has already
made it